das glück wohnt an vielen orten auf
dieser welt orte die so unterschiedlich
sind wie die menschen die danach suchen
manche lassen sich bei ihrer suche von
der sehnsucht leiten andere von der
hoffnung
jedes jahr verlassen tausende
schweizerinnen und schweizer unser land
für immer
sie werden angezogen von der exotischen
schönheit der ferne oder auch von
vertrauten landschaften
[Musik]
vor zwei jahren haben wir vier familien
begleitet als sie das abenteuer in
angriff genommen haben
sie leisten in die kanadische wildnis
[Musik]
auf die ferieninsel bali
nach italien
und nach peru wir haben alle noch einmal
besucht und festgestellt dass sie in
ihrem neuen leben endgültig angekommen
sind
doch zuerst schauen wir wie alles
angefangen hat damals vor zwei jahren
[Musik]
sie alle gingen auf und davon
christine schönbächler und ihr mann
hermann sie zogen mit ihren kindern
richtig und natascha nach kanada anja
kinski und claude wegmann wollten sich
in italien ein agriturismo aufbauen mit
dabei war dino der trüffel und anni kuhn
und orlando stamm gaben ihrer jungen
liebe ein neues zuhause auf bali bauten
sie eine ferienanlage jennifer wettstein
ihr mann ali und der kleine sven
versprachen sich in peru eine bessere
zukunft in lima sollten ihre träume wahr
werden
[Musik]
es mag die sehnsucht sein die den
menschen immer wieder einen neuanfang
wagen lässt die sehnsucht nach einem
leben in freiheit und ohne zwang
während die einen versuchen das glück in
kleinen portionen in ihrem alltag zu
finden packen die anderen den alltag in
große container und suchen das glück in
der ferne und einer von ihnen ist ali
wettstein den berner zieht es zusammen
mit seiner frau jenny nach peru
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einige tage später an der pazifikküste
in südamerika hier ist das neue zuhause
von ali wettstein seiner frau jenny und
von sven für jenny ist es nach jahren in
bayern eine art heimkehr in den schoß
ihrer familie für alliance wenn ist es
der start in ein neues leben erleichtert
wird der schritt dadurch dass dennis'
mutter und ihr bruder hier in lima leben
und arbeiten
da der container mit den möbeln noch
nicht im büro eingetroffen ist nutzt die
neue großfamilie die zeit für einen
ausflug ans meer und auf den fischmarkt
[Gelächter]
obwohl er nur soll gäste
[Musik]
zur gleichen zeit im januar 2010 bei den
reichen und schönen im engadin
[Musik]
ab 5
hier leben 2 die ebenfalls weg wollen
anni kuhn und orlando stammen sind erst
seit vier jahren ein paar
jetzt wollen sie nach bali auswandern
[Musik]
vor drei monaten haben anni und orlando
auf der götter insel bali mit dem bau
einer hotelanlage begonnen
jetzt stehen sie kurz vor der abreise in
den ewigen sommer und vor einem
schmerzhaften abschied von ihren kindern
[Applaus]
für sie haben wir nachher kann
ich freue mich wahnsinnig zum geier und
ich habe schon das abschieben
wie alle auswanderer lassen anni und
orlando geliebte menschen zurück in
ihrem fall sind das die vier söhne von
anni und die tochter und der sohn von
alan doch den tränen zum trotz überwiegt
das glück zweier liebender die weite
umwege gehen mussten bis sie nach
langjährigen ehen endlich zueinander
fanden überhaupt nicht plane zum
irgendwann das schwingen denn oder sache
und wir sind einfach mal sind also ich
hatte ich ein comeback
und plötzlich das einfach über jene
tsunami einrichten der zunahme ist
einfach und drei minuten und ist einfach
wunderbar für euch heiße
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am 31 januar 2010 ist es soweit
alle kinder der beiden sind an den
flughafen nach kloten gekommen um adieu
zu sagen
gemeinsam
[Musik]
und aktiv
das wirklich
menschen
[Musik]
glaubs
kurz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nur wenige wochen zuvor in biel ist kurz
vor weihnachten und zum letzten mal
betreibt der förster und holzkünstler
hermann schönbächler zusammen mit seiner
familie einen stand am wähler
weihnachtsmarkt die schönbächlers stehen
kurz davor sich ihren lang gehegten
traum zu erfüllen
sie werden schon bald nach kanada
auswandern das blut wird
obwohl der schritt jahre lang geplant
ist und die reise schon in ein paar
tagen ansteht deutet bis jetzt wenig auf
den abschied der familie hin
bedeutet die zocker war der report
richtig kommen probiere diesmal die
packen wir das zu bekommen
endlich geht's los auch hermanns mutter
elisabeth ist mit zum flughafen gereist
um abschied zu nehmen
seit 30 jahren träumt hermann von einem
leben in kanada seine mutter hat stets
gehofft dass es nur ein traum bleibt ja
als hermann sich von seiner mutter
elisabeth verabschiedet spürt man wie
viel die beiden miteinander verbindet
und gleichzeitig voneinander trennt
sie lieben das
[Musik]
note 2
gut in form
schon vor ein paar monaten waren
herrmann und christine hier
sie haben sich alles angeschaut ein haus
gesucht und gefunden doch nun nach
langen flügen und langer autofahrt ist
alles anders als noch im herbst ab jetzt
sind sie hier zu hause
[Musik]
anja kinski und claude wegmann brauchten
nicht lange um festzustellen dass sie
dieselben ideen haben italien ein leben
in der natur tiere garten frische luft
und gäste bewirten
bevor sie nach italien auswandern kaufen
sich anja und claude heute einen trüffel
und ich habe ja vorher schon hunde meine
eltern als ich als kinder und insofern
ist das für mich jetzt ich nichts
komplett neues aber ich muss sagen dass
früher da hat man einfach den hund dann
gehabt um sich gar nicht so damit
beschäftigt und diesmal gebe ich mir da
die gut weil das auch mein erster
eigener und ist mehr mühe um alles
richtig zu machen und ich freue mich
natürlich unheimlich gino ist ein
labrador romagnolo ein richtiger trüffel
und geben und sein neues zuhause wird in
italien in der region marke sein da wo
es viele trüffel gibt
aber so schön ruhig gänzlich
überarbeitet
[Musik]
taylor
reifen krank wird diese tradition
geworden ja gern aus
ein bisschen
[Musik]
nach 8 stündige fahrt erreichen anja und
claude saladino hier haben sie im herbst
ein anwesen gekauft dass sie nun in
eigenregie in ein agriturismo verwandeln
wollen hauptstrom glück gehabt
aber china
guck mal irgendwelche fremden ihr hausen
[Musik]
von dolce vita in italien sind anja und
claude zu diesem zeitpunkt weit entfernt
zu viel arbeit steht bevor und da hat
sie sich aufmachen um auf der gemeinde
ihren wohnsitz anzumelden beginnen sie
zu ahnen was bürokratie in italien
bedeutet
[Musik]
es ist dies zwar ihr erster aber mit
sicherheit nicht ihr letzter besuch in
einer italienischen amtsstube
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die aufenthaltsbewilligung und die
modalitäten haben anni kuhn und orlando
stamm zu ihrem glück schon bei ihrem
letzten besuch auf der götter insel
hinter sich gebracht
links war ist derzeit so hoffen sie dass
sie sich ganz auf die schönen seiten
konzentrieren können auf den bau einer
ferienanlage
jedes mal ja
unter palmen direkter mehr entsteht ein
kleines ferienparadies
hier wollen anni und orlando
balinesische square mit schweizer
qualität kombinieren
übrig blieb nur eine kommune war ja das
ist jesus darsteller mit dem neben mit
dem pool h
bereits einen schritt weiter ist ali
wettstein über der wohnung seiner
schwiegermutter sarah errichtet der
gelernte haustechnik installateur für
sich und seine kleine familie ein neues
zuhause
[Musik]
es bleibt also nichts anderes übrig als
die möbel die eben erst geliefert worden
sind in sicherheit zu bringen
jenny begleitet derweil ihren sohn sven
in die kinderkrippe
sven hat sich schnell an seine neue
umgebung gewöhnt
ali wird in lima nicht mehr auf dem
erlernten beruf auf dem bau arbeiten
sondern ein restaurant führen dass
dennis' mutter gehört seit langer zeit
wurde nicht mehr in das unternehmen
investiert ali soll das nun an die hand
nehmen
auch unter den ohnehin spärlichen gästen
hat es ausgerechnet ein paar ungebetene
kakerlaken
aber ali war noch nie einer der sich
unterkriegen lässt und seine
bescheidenheit hilft ihm wenn das geld
in der kasse unter den erwartungen
bleibt
[Musik]
110 tiere wenn man rechnet hier zu sehr
von der zone
die menschen aus wenn ich an der stelle
ja irgendwann haben wir extrem sport und
das geld
[Musik]
gegeben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vollmer halbe jahr wärme dann auch noch
durch sicherung gemacht haben das ganze
gebilde stock auch zu wort gehorchen sie
dass man überhaupt über alle inneren
können
jetzt habe ich mich natürlich aber sagen
wir schwindelfrei ist natürlich
gläubiger also das geht dann nicht
schlussendlich kann man da jetzt ohne
drin sind das waren wir definierten aus
honig und da soll dann einige monster
mit dem schweine und jetzt natürlich
gestürzt ist dass wir in der nächsten
runde das land auf die falsche seite die
betriebs ökonomen und der werber lieben
herausforderungen
deshalb haben sie kein fertighaus
gekauft und stehen jetzt vor einem berg
arbeit unterstützt werden sie dabei von
anja schwester nina die fitness
instruktorin ist an diesem projekt
finanziell beteiligt
[Musik]
die fast nicht mehr
wow
in bali sind die arbeiten an der
ferienanlage weit vorangeschritten
wir setzen und wirklichkeit und das ist
immer noch obwohl sie genau so wie ich
das grund unter sehr gut so waren wir da
auf den baustellen sind die cis
technologie ist einfach gut doch
irgendwie bis einfach komme aber die
stimme für die nötige gefahr begeben wo
ich ganz jung soo lee kino jetzt machen
wir mal macht das also beschloss ich
dass die innere jahre kloster ich alles
perfekt aber das ist die hauptbotschaft
adolph hat deutschsprachig voran straße
biotech 56 meter leitung möchte sie für
pa verbindet einfach machen und dann
hätte strom oder und das bringen da
drehen jetzt nicht reißt sie wenn sie
werden einfach nötig die moment nämlich
war der wien-wahl 100 an private da und
langsam wird es den jobeinstieg mit dem
buffet wochen die steuer heftig und
dennoch mehr als strom habe und dort
pohl der laufenden strom kein wasser
pumpen in den wasserturm also kein
mensch in den letzten vierzehn tag der
wirklichkeit fuß anac und den auch an
den generator kauf
in den wäldern rund um roth ist hermann
schönbächler seiner traumvorstellung
eines lebens abseits der zivilisation
sehr nahe gekommen weil es aber auch in
der kanadischen wildnis nicht ohne
festes einkommen geht und weil hermann
ein mann der tat kraft ist wird er heute
seinen neuen job an
er soll hier eine bald pacht nachhaltig
bewirtschaften und als erstes ein paar
bäume fällen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sein vorgesetzter ist von der
präzisionsarbeit des schweizers
sichtlich beeindruckt
[Musik]
das leben im nordwesten kanadas ist ein
einziges abenteuer
[Applaus]
und jede bootsfahrt mit der familie kann
in dieser gegend zum bleibenden erlebnis
werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vom nahen ufer her beobachtet ein
schwarzbär die auswanderer und der motor
ihres bootes springt nicht mehr an
[Musik]
hermann will nichts riskieren und
befiehlt den geordneten rückzug
[Applaus]
warum warum warum heißt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf die junge familie wettstein in lima
wartet ein ganz anderes abenteuer rallye
wird seine familie für drei monate
alleine lassen nun in der schweiz zu
arbeiten und so die familienkasse
aufzubessern läuft dort hilfe für mich
ist meine unterstützung ist was man
achse und alle natürlich war der
abschied fällt nicht leicht aber in der
schweiz canali innert dreier monate ein
vielfaches verdienen und so die familie
über wasser halten
jenny wird inzwischen versuchen ihr
eigenes geschäft mit babyartikeln zum
laufen zu bringen
dafür macht sie in einem warenhaus an
jedem wochenende werbung
[Musik]
pauli hingegen arbeitet zehntausend
kilometer entfernt von seinen liebsten
bei seinem ehemaligen arbeitgeber im
kanton bern auf dem bau die 6000 franken
im monat sind für ali eine finanzielle
absicherung sicheren optionen würde sich
nicht unbedingt diese optionen als
minister
als die familie schönbächler in biel
lebten wohnten die vier in einer
bescheidenen wohnung in einem wohnblock
heute haben sie ein riesiges haus und
noch mehr garten zur verfügung
[Musik]
wo vorher gewohnt hat vorher sind uns
egal was ihr gelesen oder rückwärts
gemacht
jetzt fast philosophisch sami hyypiä 11
mit dem mittel zugeführt werden
die hält der sachverhalt zu diesem
garten
es macht ihr das das motiviert hat
[Musik]
50 ob lohse wohnbau es ist juni 2010 als
die götter auf bali genügend gebete oder
aber die beamten der insel genügend
steuern zum schweizer paar kassiert
haben
jedenfalls fließt nun im ferien resort
des schweizer auswanderer paares endlich
strom und dusche
[Musik]
obwohl die arbeiten an der hotelanlage
noch nicht beendet sind wein der
ehemalige vermessungsingenieur und die
hauswirtschaftslehrerin ihr kleines
paradies am 26 juni 2010 ein an der
farbenprächtigen und kostspieligen
zeremonie nimmt das ganze dorf teil
[Musik]
und schon kurze zeit später kann der
architekt sein werk den schweizern
übergeben
[Musik]
okay hier in der warum
bislang kam es down that's ok ok geben
wir das gerne auf
ein letzter fast ein jahr lang haben
anni und orlando den bau ihrer anlage
begleitet haben gehofft sich geärgert
und immer wieder haben sie sich gefreut
auf diesen moment so schön aber dass ich
hab mich sehr
und die würden dazu teilnehmer so sind
dabei das aggregat ja ja denn natürlich
freund will jeden tag und und volkan
sich kontrolle zu wahren
noch fällt es schwer zu glauben dass da
wo einst tiere untergebracht waren und
aus einem stein trug fraßen schon bald
gäste in schönen zimmern übernachten
sollen
doch claude ist gewillt den gegenbeweis
anzutreten
[Musik]
vorstellt zum konzept von anja und
claude gehören tiere pferde ziegen
schweine und hühner sollen auf dem hof
leben und die machen wir jetzt einen
gesunden eindruck ich muss zugeben ich
habe nicht so wahnsinnig viel ahnung von
dem thema auf einer nahegelegenen
hühnerfarm kaufen die auswanderer ihre
ersten nutztiere
[Musik]
das nahelegen
ach ich finde das jetzt schön den
zuzuschauen erster bauen gespannt hoffen
wir mal dass der fuchs nicht hier
demnächst ein blutbad anrichtet
noch vor wenigen monaten träumten anni
und orlando davon in bali zu leben und
da auch gäste beherbergen zu können
im herbst 2010 ist es endlich so weit
der bau der anlage hat zwar energie
gekostet ihrer liebe aber nichts anhaben
können
ok
[Musik]
stolz steigen sie auf ihren wasserturm
und schauen auf ihr kleines paradies
[Musik]
drei monate lang war jenny mit ihrem
sohn sven allein in peru ihr mann ali
hat in dieser zeit in der schweiz
geschuftet um die familienkasse
aufzubessern
jetzt habt wenn sein papa endlich wieder
ali ist seit ein paar wochen zurück
gemeinsam können sie sich ein wochenende
im peruanischen hinterland
nein
[Musik]
bevor es an das weiß man genießt war den
winkel nur dem streiten und hatten keine
zeit für uns gerade überhaupt keine und
das war wirklich so dass man das alles
gefühlt
es ist weniger finalist neues
[Musik]
im moment ist alles gut wir haben ein
bisschen gebraucht auf diese drei monate
nutzen vermissen
[Musik]
inzwischen hat sich auch die situation
in alice restaurant wesentlich
verbessert doch nicht nur der
verbesserte geschäftsgang ist es der zur
zufriedenheit von ali und jenny beiträgt
nach alice rückkehr aus der schweiz
haben sich die beiden die größte freude
gleich selber bereitet zur selben zeit
im herbst 2010 ist im nordwesten kanadas
auch christine schönwälder schwanger
als sich der himmel an einem abend im
oktober verdunkelt und winde aufziehen
die sich zu einem sturm entwickeln
[Musik]
der tag danach bietet ein bild das es
selbst einem furchtlosen man wie hermann
schönbächler angst und bange wird
[Musik]
so schlimm muss man hoffen dass kleines
austragen
durchaus das ist da hier das ist aber ob
sie mit großer einzige einzige
zwei sie warum das das letzte was durch
sonderschauen
dass hermann in diesem augenblick nicht
ermessen kann fast 200 hektaren wald
liegen am boden
seine aussicht in den nächsten 20 jahren
hier eine waldwirtschaft zu betreiben so
wie er das in der schweiz gelernt hat
einen sich stets verjüngenden dauer wald
mit bäumen aller arten und größen diese
aussicht ist in einer einzigen nacht
zerstört worden
[Musik]
doch wenn die familie schönbächler eines
weiß dann dies der herr nimmt nicht nur
ergibt auch am 22 januar 2011 ist das
glück wieder ins haus im wald eingezogen
das nicht unbedingt wählen und ja der
grund dafür dass ich das schön
alexandra estate steht für das glück
dass unsere auswanderer in den ersten
monaten in der neuen heimat erleben
durften
diese kleinen und großen abenteuer
liegen bereits ein jahr und mehr zurück
für uns ein guter grund alle noch einmal
einen besuch abzustatten um zu sehen was
das leben inzwischen gebracht hat
sie spiegeln
[Musik]
laut wegmann hat schwein physisch so
zeigt ihnen die ja wirklich schön blöd
führt heute das leben von dem er lange
geträumt hat ein leben als kleinbauer in
der region marke in italien als larven
aus burscheid so dass es mir vorgestellt
habe
fischbacher die achse twist geteilt hast
willst du hast das ich halte es abhängig
vom wartung empfehlen könne mache das
war angenehm auf
aber ich lasse hier aus dem berufsstand
wie man nicht kann hier bei neuwagen
fast zwei jahre lang haben blut und
seine partnerin anja kind die mehr oder
weniger allein
agriturismo gearbeitet jetzt haben sie
zu unterstützung eine baufirma engagiert
dienstleister dieser stelle einfach zu
windig und passt ja nicht alle maschinen
auch möglichkeiten zu mir
ein folgenreicher ist auch das thema ein
satzverhältnis mitglieder fleißig auf
den grund fordert der lch ausgabe
anja arbeitet nur noch im
auftragsverhältnis für ihren früheren
arbeitgeber
das sichert sie finanziell zumindest
teilweise ab ihre erfüllung wollte sich
aber hier
wenn hier auch nicht alle arbeiten
gleichermaßen spaß machen
nebenan ist das zweite die sind jetzt
endlich fertig und das ist jetzt ein
schönes gefühl
oder macht spaß die so zu sehen war sehr
viel arbeit
und jetzt hat man ja auch schon die
ersten gäste und ja also es macht sehr
viel spaß zu sehen wie die sachen so
langsam werden
der boden das ist hier so einen original
boden wir hier in der gegend sehr häufig
verwendet wird das ist sind terrakotta
steine die haben der claude und ich
verlegt ist eigentlich so geworden wie
wir es uns vorgestellt haben
hier haben sich es sich jetzt um gäste
die ein paar tage hier sind das heißt
ihre putze ich einfach einmal durch muss
aber nicht also die gäste machen gerade
einen fahrradausflug habe ich jetzt auch
ein bisschen zeit muss aber nicht das
zimmer komplett putzen im sinne von
vorbereiten für neue gäste
so gesehen ist es natürlich etwas
weniger aufwendig
also diese tätigkeit für dich nicht als
mein hobby bezeichnen aber es ist jetzt
auch nichts was mir extrem schwerfällt
meine jeder putzt er auch bei sich zu
hause und wenn man die zimmer auch jeden
tag putzt also wir hatten bisher auch
nicht die erfahrung dass sie jetzt
extrem verschmutzt sind
also insofern es macht mir nichts aus
und liegt auch daran die sachen so
entstand zu halten
zusammen mit anja und glut schauen wir
zurück auf einzelne augenblicke ihres
abenteuers geladen sehen und die
gebäudesubstanz einschätzen denn je
länger je mehr befürchten die
auswanderer dass die renovationsarbeiten
weit aufwendiger werden als bisher
angenommen und die mauer
die sind also sozusagen die sind gut
aber dass darin kann man soll das raus
lassen so dass das dann nicht
überschaubar
sie wäre und man kann dort nach wie vor
lang zieht dann hat er nicht das glück
haben wie man sich das vielleicht letzte
lehrgang ist ja okay das haben
vielleicht nicht beachtet für uns war
wichtig dass die außenmauern dass die
eigentlich stehen dann können dass die
noch stabil sind
das hatte er damals bestätigt und
insofern kann ich das nur auch wieder
bestätigen was claude gerade gesagt hat
dass es keine negative überraschung war
damals für uns
[Musik]
in der peruanischen hauptstadt lima sind
jenny und ali am ersten juli 2011 zum
zweiten mal eltern geworden
der kleine noah hat das glück der
familie perfekt gemacht und jetzt wollen
sie ihre freude am liebsten allen
mitteilen
und weil jenny eine produktelinie für
babysachen anbietet kommt klein noah als
model gerade richtig
im nachgang zum glauben bisher im moment
so müde wir haben so viel zu tun das
comeback war eine schöne idee haben wie
neue produkte plus restaurant ist man
voll
wir haben keine hilfe wir machen alles
und alleine
aber wenn wir die gelassen von nur
selten als hat weder 10 k und auch von
sven genie sagt sie sei glücklich es
fehle ihr an nichts
ich bin eine frau einmal so ich kann
nichts mehr
nicht nur deshalb ist perfekt ich mache
alles was ich möchte so habe alles alles
sie haben
ich habe zwei perfekte schöne alles um
kinder
so was kann ich noch mal fragen kann ob
der stoff türkei auch mit der familie
wettstein blicken wir zurück
wahrscheinlich ist es die sehnsucht
vieler menschen auch ein nicht mehr ganz
neue sessel
im penalty den markt gebracht wird das
nicht ich mache also die ganz kommt ihr
in peru mit
außerdem schlug mir sein extremes an und
da bin ich freue mich dass das wäre
nicht nur für harley ist das neue
zuhause für jenny eine altersrente das
heißt es ja ich war doch wer eine police
dem hier tag mit viel angst gehabt um
art von ein taxi nehmen
ich glaube meine ruhe und so das alles
hier zu viel das eine was für kleine
sache wir sind ist nicht mehr geld wir
haben wir den straffen taxifahrer haben
familie
das bild das bz
[Applaus]
ein kleines häufig halte ich für extrem
große fortschritte gemacht mit dem
wahnsinn ja muss ich hab ein herz für
kinder geht
[Musik]
pauli im herbst 2011 ein jahr ist seit
unserem letzten besuch bei orlando
stammen und an ihm vergangen
gäste sind da
mit boris kriegsrecht muss also ein
handy hat es laut stiko um 50 prozent
und das eigentlich schon über dem oder
dass auch extreme hersteller wäre schon
sehr gut und nicht ein jahrzehnt im red
star sieht man vor laufen hält sieht man
von elektrizität und grobheit und das
eigentlich sehr gut
inzwischen beschäftigen anni und orlando
über ein dutzend mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter aus dem dorf in ihren
unternehmen ist erstmals richtig schön
einfach mal am morgen hinweg es klappt
renault will aber jetzt er sich bereits
im schweizer team das feld ganz klar
hinter rot ist eigentlich alles das sind
alles fähig die bürger und viele sind
einfach zu sorglos
das ist mein im oktober fertig pauker
und hängt strom kappis im februar um
hannah marie angestellte schock und mit
löhnt zahlt und es ist halt immer noch
zahlt 0 1 alt und aus kwk imame und
gebar ivo ihnen sind in 82 das ist
einfach nicht lang mit aber es ist schon
irgendwie gegangen
im nachhinein ich es nicht so schlimm
aber daheim anne-christin was passiert
weit zurückliegen die momente des
abschieds schmerzes aber vergessen sind
sie nicht
[Musik]
abschied der saison - schöne sache ich
würde ich war das mit seite afrika und
mehr gewicht um mehr gehen jetzt noch
ineinander die stadt mit den einnahmen
das land ein anderer kontinent weiter
weg eigentlich und das ist auch jetzt
ist wer die mutter ist jetzt gegeben und
jetzt muss ich sein und das ist schon
untergegangen
also es ist also ist ein schlechter
moment sehr ermöglichen ein harter
moment sehen
[Musik]
und da sieht man wirklich als sie das
wirklich den alex habe ich nicht einmal
mein pfleger
das ist fast schon so wie flügel
[Musik]
selbstverständlich besuchen wir auch die
familie schönbächler im kanadischen
märchenwald von rost
christine und alexander aber auch
natascha und ricky sind wohlauf und
hermann sowieso wenn ihm nicht kratzt
der bald abhanden kommt
[Musik]
es war ein bewegtes erstes jahr für die
auswanderer familie aus biel und es
folgte ein zweites jahr das ebenfalls
aufregend begann mit der geburt des
dritten kindes alexandra schwangerschaft
ich viel austragen und geburt und die
spitalaufenthalt das wirklich machen
ich weiß ja nicht absichtlich oder nicht
abends schauen wir auch mit herrmann und
christine schönbächler zurück eine szene
die vor einem jahr viel zu reden gab war
das schwierige verhältnis von hermann zu
seiner mutter elisabeth auch heute noch
spricht hermann nur ungern darüber
[Musik]
irgendwie hat sie schon kaufen um
sicherheit
cdu und spd hatten es auch eigentlich
eine fehlstellung mit dem gleichen tag
silber
[Musik]
das schlimmste ist schlimm strom nach
europa sehe das papier der arzt
das probiere festhalten
das ist nicht schön woher verschnitt
licher be misunderstood unter sechs
minuten company wäre da nicht die
[Musik]
tourismusverbände angst haben muss der
nötige respekt aber sicher nicht
angegeben richtig was ich schwarz
schwarz gelb würde chris lee überbelegt
sicher bloomberg riesling überlegt sich
die fresse oder wollte die mit fleiß und
überlegt die fließe die das ist der
unterschied zwischen einer bahre mit dem
land verbringt aussehen aufgewachsen und
untereinander fakt was passiert sei
zwischen zwei wochen muss mit bayer
punkt
[Musik]
die tiere auf dem hof in italien sind
zwar manchmal ein wenig stürmisch aber
harmlos
[Musik]
guten morgen das sind dieser tage die
autoren fordern alte die brunnen und
ertrag im januar ein geister bock ich
möchte noch nicht ganz so einem bock
schmeckt nicht mehr jahre kann er dann
immer noch sie haben blut wegmann war
dabei als der bock zur welt kam
ja es ist lästig sie wiedergeburt aus
mannheim gewann so ungefähr aufkommt und
bitte einfach zufällig im stark ist also
2 3 tage früher und es irgendwie komisch
ist und dann ist relativ schnell
gegangen ist rokoko mega spannend also
ein geburtig geburt aber dann so leicht
wie ich natürlich schon etwas anders und
schwer doch die schnell los sie und sie
hatten dann abgeschlagen sind aber doch
gehört wurde und dann holt zur farbe sie
hat einen stromkreis später stand es wie
briefmarken
es ist ja nicht anfangen abgleichen und
bildern im stall xii das sind kratzer
kollegen und ich hab ich sie ein
falsches leben romantisch und
beschließen wie es sich entwickelt hat
als ein vertreter haben so problemlos
klappt dann ist natürlich
vor einem jahr war es in erster linie
claude der mithilfe von anja den
großteil der arbeit am agriturismo
verrichtete heute lebt auch anjas
schwester nina bei den beiden sie hat
ihren job als fitness expertin in los
angeles aufgegeben und ist nach italien
gezogen heute haben die schwestern
besuch von bettina einer der wenigen
bewohnerinnen hier in der umgebung leben
unheimlich weniger leute noch im dorf
san martino es ist ähnlich wie in vielen
denke ich weiterleben dörfern dass die
jungen leute wegziehen und bleiben
einfach nur noch die die älteren
menschen hier mal ist hier auch muss man
sagen aufeinander angewiesen wenn so
wenige leute und empfiehlt nur sondern
ist einfach nett wenn man die nachbarn
fragen kann ich finde das total
interessant diese feigen des teiges
diese stellte es war wirklich eine eine
eine liebes liebeserklärung an die nudel
wenn man das so oft die traditionelle
weise macht
bettina gibt heute ein gutes stück pasta
traditionen anja und nina weiter
seit 80 jahren macht sie die teigwaren
so wie sie es einst von ihrer mutter
gelernt hat das alter der dame lassen
hier an dieser stelle vornehmen
unerwähnt das nudelholz hingegen das sei
verraten ist 100 jahre alt
anja nina aber auch claude dürfen für
sich in anspruch nehmen dass sie immer
wieder neue dinge ausprobieren
auch wenn nicht immer alles auf anhieb
geklappt hat wie der blick zurück
beweist
in italien droht wegmann und an ihr kind
zu tun modernen technik diesmal dauert
ausgegeben hat das ausland her und
kloten in ihren berufen bisher vor allem
kopf arbeit geleistet jetzt geht es um
handfeste probleme bis jetzt noch immer
darüber gesprochen ein ja oder august
man findet ja und jetzt neue motor sind
sie besser aufregend so etwas noch nie
auf einer bühne sondern vorher mal
ausprobiert hat wieder ist ja noch
niederlagen
sie haben sie nicht hochkam und
professionell ist eine chronologie die
alex ii
sein
die affäre ist
weil man ja im nachhinein stelle ich das
auch fest dass ich damals wohl ziemlich
genervt war weil ich irgendwie nicht so
richtig verstanden hatte was er wollte
oder das gefühl hat er hat es mehr
falsch erklärt es kommt natürlich immer
mal wieder vor in der zusammenarbeit
dass irgendetwas nicht funktioniert und
er der meinung ist ich jetzt so machen
sollen und ich dann der meinung er hat
es mir falsch erklärt und ja weil wir
hier auch viel arbeiten verrichten mit
maschinen oder sachen auch die ich noch
nie gemacht habe wo ich mich nicht so
auskennen und er der meinung ist das
müsste ich doch wissen und da gibt es
manchmal die ein oder andere kappeler
also mein mann so ist projekttage oder
sowohl stunden hat sich
meinungsverschiedenheit aber sitzt nicht
verstehen um eine ausgewachsene kraft
bis mehr aus dem sinn dass der cube
optimiert strahlend weiß jetzt nicht
aber wenn strittig und payment nicht
wahr ist auch dass auf dem möglichen
entscheiden dies auch
[Musik]
ali wettstein ist meist ein
aufgestellter zeitgenosse erst recht
wenn sein pasta restaurant in lima gut
besetzt ist
in den letzten 12 monaten konnten ali
und sein team den umsatz fast
vervierfachen
jetzt denkt er darüber nach das
restaurant zu erweitern
vorbei sind die zeiten da die
angestellten zum nichtstun gezwungen
waren
streit stand sie sind dass man mut
machen dass sie das machen wir die nicht
schlagen wenn ihr diese luft
[Musik]
technisch super im museum schneeflocken
entspannt können ali und jenny heute auf
die anfänge im restaurant zurückblicken
[Musik]
und ihrem umweg sieben restaurants el
bulli gates
entschuldigung ich kenne ja so schön und
gut
in bali gibt es für die angestellten von
orlando stammen und an ikonen jeden tag
kleine arbeiten zu erledigen arbeiten
die der chef aus sicherer distanz
verfolgt und den sinn
chicago sid funktionär zu nehmen es
jetzt ausgewechselt aber die neue tour
oder aber nicht wirklich irgend ein
bisschen kabel am kontakt dass erding
durchgeschmort sicherlich warsitz
problem ich weiß nicht am schluss muss
ich eigentlich nie wieder ein echter
fachmann für das schwächeln
es ist noch gar nicht lange her da war
nicht zu viel strom das problem sondern
zu wenig strom
darauf von der oberlahn andere stange
selber kaufen natürlich auch kein strom
krieg dass ich solche leidiges thema und
eigentlich hatte jennifer minetti vom
recht und wähle das einfach genug ist
die großen christbaum miteinander treten
aber dass ich fahre ich habe gesagt dass
durch die mutation mehrheit
stromanschluss ist ganz gut aus und das
rivale fischer vom luxus dar
dieser luxus kostete umgerechnet manchen
franken und noch mehr nerven ab dass wir
da alles hinter ausländer unbewertet
gnadenlos gerupft also mehr geld und das
büro beziehen sie holte später
kletterhalle lieber alles so die
medaille hätte 27 und hinter dem vorhang
vom theater realistischen her und das
ist so als wenn man länger lebt darauf
paar ideen entmystifiziert sich halt das
paradies show
wir hätten mit der behörde und da merkt
man dass man mehr als ausländer denn
auch wirklich nicht also sagt landwirt
und also da ist jemand der so einige
eier genau und als drittes den schuh
laut ifpi moskau
tascha muss zur schule das mädchen
besucht in kanada die erste klasse und
papa hermann fährt sie heute früh
morgens bis zum schulbus
dieser bringt sie dann ins dreiviertel
stunden entfernte terrors für hermann
sind dass die seltenen augenblicke in
denen er einige der wenigen bewohner von
ross gut zu gesicht bekommt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
the world
denn die kiste
anschließend fährt auch hermann
schönbächler zur arbeit in seinem wald
oder in das was davon im herbst 2010
übrig geblieben ist
[Musik]
das ist nicht wie vor augen auf den mehr
oder weniger als 200 euro mit 1 12
sekunden hat dass es sie mit dem motto
windschott das ist deix event in die
nächsten 20 jahre hat die wahl wurde
forschten und das projekt irgendwie
zwischen plante die kulturbauten und sex
am puffer nachhaltiger forstwirtschaft
statt jeden tag im nordwesten von kanada
das war stück weg die sturmschäden sind
nicht nur bis heute unübersehbar auch
bei hermann schönbächler hat das
gewaltige naturereignis seine spuren
hinterlassen haben
dudas knickt vor deiner bei ihm ist es
husum und dass das komplette substanz
dass das ist
das ist gar nicht schön sie hatte mit
minus eröffnen im grundkurs gesperrt
beim bildungshaus karriere und ruf
sketch der hus ja das sind einfach ganz
viel schaden wirklich harte untergrund
popstar ermordet
dies ist der platz doch noch haben muss
aber natur und irgendwie zu resignieren
oder 20 euro hilft ist dank des akkus
machen
noch keine einzige sekunde hat hermann
bereut hierher gekommen zu sein
hey müsste ich jetzt kann oder will hat
uns heute tritt sie wieder schweiz
hinaus holzfenster was in der schweiz
was wir also ich und die da ich und die
danach um höchste job
sechsstellig sie kommen im jahr oder um
neue backup hofer und das großes boot
kaufen oder unter unten
aber das ist nicht das was ich suche
es ist das glück dass die einen in
lauter umgebung suchen und die anderen
exotischen ferne
zwei jahre nach ihrem abschied aus der
schweiz denken anni und orlando nur noch
selten an ihr früheres leben zurück und
dann vermissen sie nur etwas ihre kinder
sonst jedoch scheinen sie ihr glück in
bali gefunden zu haben
unglaublich das blatt er sich nur zum
spielen blatt ab
[Applaus]
das sind somit von kokosnuss erschlagen
wollte dazu hype ist sowohl mit der ak
hin aber das völlig das thema möglicher
wir abschneiden da dass man was man
sicherheit geleistet habe denn vergesst
wir haben aber er weiß wer wie das
funktioniert wird das gute ist ehrlich
geantwortet
ok
[Musik]
es ist november 2011
als anja kinski ihre schwester nina und
chlodwig man einen weiteren kleinen aber
symbolträchtigen schritt machen um dir
einst als selbstversorger in italien
leben zu können
also hier die ersten davon sollten her
machen wir denn hier dreiecks mäßig so
zum abstützen nicht gut markiert einfach
dass man darauf hin dass das ist dass
auf dem warmbad ja schon ziemlich symbol
karte für häuser zu einem wichtig ist
aber auch dass man äpfel beim hand das
für euch geist und und berechnend dir
also noch etwas aber produziere ich
relativ wichtig oder warme unbedingt
also das könnte am griff haben dass
wahrscheinlich kein die kleine dürfen
bäume ja jetzt ist das trio perfekt sind
wir ja seit einigen monaten zu dritt was
auch gut ist weil genügend arbeit ist ja
vorhanden und für mindestens 3
und eigentlich vier ja auch mit ihm
ansieht dokumentieren fürs familienalbum
damit wir dann auch wissen welche am
besten gewachsen ist meine schwester hat
jahrelang in amerika gelebt da sieht man
sich natürlich nicht so häufig und jetzt
sind wir hier wieder vereint lassen in
diesem jahr
und das ist eigentlich sehr schön hier
ist ein tolles gefühl wenn man seinen
zukünftigen nahrungsmittel eben wenn man
sich darum selbst kümmern kann man sich
nicht auch dass tusch auf supermärkte
verlassen muss und die qualität
natürlich ganz andere
wir haben ja auch hier nachbarin die
alle äpfel apfelbäume haben und die habe
ich schon viele von ihnen können
gegessen und die schmecken einfach
richtig ein apfel und nicht nach plastik
auch betriebs kommunen anpacken das
modell taufe unserer machterbe fest was
wir geld allein die suche nach dem glück
sei es die glücklich machen heißt es
kein wunder dass die zwischenbilanz der
drei auswanderer in italien positiv
ausfällt
fazit 100 zeit war bisher viel arbeit
viele unterschiedliche dinge die getan
werden musste nur noch zu tun sind aber
es ist wunderschön hier das gefällt uns
nach wie vor sehr gut und wir würden es
bestimmt noch mal so machen und dann
werden wir natürlich hoffentlich viele
viele gäste haben und das dann machen
was wir eigentlich machen wollten gäste
meist läuft kann ich jetzt da muss man
gar nicht mehr so viel zu bieten können
die ganzen umbauten fertig sind aber ich
danke für die landwirtschaft her
das bewegt aber immer jemand der oft
wahlkomitee sie aber man will kreiert
bier hans die ganze zeit dass das ist
auch etwas was mich eigentlich dann
freut oder was weiß ich kann ich auch
vor dass man wirklich dass nachrücker
wirklich verwoben waren
ist es nicht schön hier ach ja und so
viele
hockey league ahl
[Musik]
zutritt haben jenny ali und sven vor
zwei jahren das abenteuer in angriff
genommen und sind von bern nach lima
ausgewandert seit der geburt von noah
ist die familie zu viert und fast
scheint es dass ali trotz
mehrbelastungen hier in südamerika ein
wenig zur ruhe gefunden hat
[Musik]
ja ja es ist auf dem besten niveau werde
täglich so viel kollege der kindergarten
oder ganztagsschule sie wirke zudem
ihrer juni zieht jetzt langsam für ihn
also müssten im selben zeitraum aber ich
sehe es stand über das judentum sowie
medizin jedes problem hat staate -
problem und probleme könne allein schon
das abenteuer auswandern mit sich
bringen also für was man umgewandelt es
um den weg ins festzelt regen leitungen
täten wir wirklich das möglich aus dem
innersten user besser loslassen
es ist wirklich ein mega stress also es
ist nicht einfach mit vakuum ist es ist
überhaupt wieso also messias power co
inspiriert das macht sie ganz anders
mentalität ist ganz anders wie man auch
mitglied absicht und so weiter und so
fort als er mich jetzt so viel hörte mit
dem zug mit allem drum und dran und mit
zwei zusammen und das ist sehr wichtig
funktionieren
und so würden dass ali an jenny wieder
tun
auswandern so wie es jahr für jahr
tausende von schweizerinnen und
schweizern tun und ein paar von ihnen
werden wir selbstverständlich bei ihrem
abenteuer wieder begleiten
[Musik]
denn die suche nach dem glück geht
weiter am sechsten januar startet die
neue staffel von auf und davon mit
diesen geschichten emma und rolf dobler
stürzen sich mit ihren drei kindern ins
große abenteuer in ihrer neuen heimat
australien will die thurgauer familie
das leben genießen und mehr zeit
füreinander haben nur mit der suche nach
einem neuen haus klappt es nicht recht
den ersten geburtstag von baby jennifer
feiert sie auf dem campingplatz mit
einer harley und großen plänen im gepäck
reisen lange und hans jörg jäger nach
thailand
[Musik]
in lommis heimatdorf wollen die aargauer
eine seniorenresidenz bauen
[Musik]
sintflutartige regenfälle bringen ihre
pläne völlig durcheinander
familie tänzer aus dem kanton bern
schleudert in ein neues leben
die dancers kaufen in florida ein haus
und wagen einen radikalen neuanfang
kater clyde denzer hatte den
alltagstrott in der schweiz nicht mehr
ausgehalten im land der unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten seinen palmen den weg ins
paradies
ja macht und wir begleiten auch in der
neuen staffel den bieler förster hermann
schönbächler der findet im kanadischen
bald nicht nur kostbare pilze sondern
das was seiner familie in der schweiz
gefehlt hat wie viel beschworene
ultimative lebensqualität
geschichten von der großen freiheit und
andere abenteuer in der neuen staffel
von auf und davon
ab dem 6 januar auf sf 1
[Musik]
das auge isst mit